make sure you guys hit the subscribe
button if you guys are enjoying the
content that we're throwing up
and uh make sure you guys hit the like
button if you enjoy the video and
yeah let's begin
what's going on guys this is rob and we
are back with death metal and this
is we're almost done this is the second
to the last part i guess it's actually a
seven issue series instead of six issues
honestly i don't really even check
online to see what the reading issues
are for death metal anymore i just just
kind of letting it go and and just
seeing
how far we get into it but i'm pretty
sure we have one more part left um
but here's the thing so in the last
video that we did the last part of the
story
we had this scenario where we basically
saw the superheroes on earth pretty much
eradicating earth right just eliminating
the entirety of
of earth itself right the earth's
populace all that kind of stuff and the
reason why
and i think this is something that was a
little bit murky in the last video that
we did so we're going to try to clarify
here the reason why is because
in dc comics this is called prime earth
right it's the main earth of dc comics
the main universe
and the the entirety of the dark
multiverse is based off the main
universe i mean i guess to a degree it
does involve alien races out there but
for the most part dc hasn't really
specified that instead
the entirety of the dark multiverse
seems to hinge on the entirety of
everything going on in the main dc uh
multiverse the main dc
prime earth because of the fact that
whenever you look at the dark multiverse
you don't really see
like dark versions of like the red
lanterns from like you know the
some some cast off planet somewhere
ismael you don't really see like a dark
version of the guardians of the universe
from like maltese or i guess really oh
as it's called now you don't really see
that instead it's all just dark versions
of earth-based characters and dark
versions of earth so it stands to reason
that if the heroes wanted to mitigate
the power of
batman who laughed that they would
basically essentially wipe out the
earth's population
because with billions and billions of
people come billions and billions and
even countless trillions of
possibilities
now even then it does require us to sort
of cook the books a little bit right
because one of the things that we know
whenever it comes to branch universe
theory
and the idea of opposite multiverses
things like that is that for every
possibility there's an infinite number
of other possibilities and it literally
just branches out to infinity so as long
as there's one superhero here there's an
infinite number of possible versions of
that superhero in the dark multiverse
every conceivable fear that superman
could have and even the fears he doesn't
even know he has right the fears on a
subconscious level
exist out there on the dark multiverse
right so it's really kind of of
scott snyder and dc taking the infinite
possibilities of dark versions of
characters and kind of reeling it in and
saying there's only
so many dark versions of characters that
we know of right so uh it's kind of
taking what is in effect an infinite
number of possibilities and just
artificially convincing them down for
the sake of telling a story right and so
because of that the only real life
that's left here on earth
are basically the superheroes that you
see here right and that's essentially it
there really isn't anything else now
the other thing that we saw is that you
saw all these different versions of uh
dark worlds that have been created by
the batman who laughs
showing up on earth right at least you
know coming towards earth and so one of
the big guesses they make here
is perhaps there is there are no other
forms of life out there right because
they they basically prematurely
cut off the power of the batman who
laughs from all the crisis energy that
existed out there and his ability to
create a whole host of new worlds
so long as perpetua has that power the
batman who laughs
does not and so he has a huge amount of
power in the form of dr manhattan but
the ability to create different
universes out there doesn't necessarily
exist right his ability to do that has
effectively been cut off and that's why
they the superheroes kind of guess and
they say okay with all the different
you know dark versions of ourselves that
we see here maybe this is it right this
is all the batman who laughs
has that there is nothing else there
once these guys are done then we
basically win right and that's why they
kind of pull out all the stops and say
okay then let's get to it if the
likelihood
existed that there were other versions
of these dark heroes on earth right so
they fight this army here when they beat
this army another army shows up when
they beat that army another army shows
up
if we saw that it was going to basically
be a war of attrition then the
superheroes would
uh stage their power out accordingly
right they would use just enough ability
to destroy these heroes and then kind of
make sure they don't exhaust themselves
right nobody wants to have the
rope-a-dope technique done on them right
when muhammad ali beat george foreman by
letting george foreman pound on him and
tire himself out right and then
go into the go in for the kill on george
foreman the superheroes don't want to
have that happen to them where they go
ham
on all these different you know this
army here and then have nothing left for
all the different other other villains
that show up or other twisted versions
of themselves that show up from across
the dark multiverse the other part of
that is we actually switch over to
wonder woman
and uh and lobo now if you guys recall
with wonder woman and lobo they're
traveling to basically the world forge
right the idea of trying to find some
way to essentially tap into
all the anti-crisis energy that exists
out there to kind of become the
antithesis
of the batman who laughs right if the
batman who laughs and perpetua
are tying into the energy that's created
from crisis worlds that they made right
so the events of crisis undefined earth
infinite crisis final crisis and those
those you know those worlds exist
because of the actual events that took
place right so the dark multiverse
counterpart
is the version of crisis on infinite
earth where the anti-monitor won
but that dark multiverse counterpart
only exists because the crisis on a
finite dose event happened if if batman
who lasts in perpetua
are tapping into that you know dark
crisis power
then what it means is wonder woman could
in turn tap into the anti-crisis energy
right the idea
of the anti-monitor not winning right
that kind of a thing they can kind of
tap into those energies uh if that's the
case
then what you should be seeing here in
the space that they're in where it's
pitch black
are all the hopes and fears and
possibilities right because what they're
traveling through is basically a tunnel
right so
imagine that like you're driving through
some tunnel to get to some location
all the cars that would be around you
represent all the fears and the hopes
and things like that
of all the various humans that exist on
earth because of the fact that all the
humans are basically gone there's only a
handful of superheroes left and that
crisis energy has effectively been cut
off there's nothing here
and the the only real last terror that
exists out there the only real
horrifying concept that exists
is now basically the batman who laughs
right and that's kind of represented by
the fact that all the the the versions
of the twisted versions of batman
superman wonder woman that all existed
that are currently on the battlefield
seem to have basically resided here at
some point in time right but they've all
been pulled out
and they're sent to that location but
because the batman who lasts is the only
real terror that's left then it's all
the fears that concern the batman who
laughs the forms he could take different
things like that now they're not given a
tangible form yet right because right
now they're just fears that exist
it seems like it's not until these fears
manifest in the physical world that they
suddenly take on a form these twisted
versions are things like the batman who
laughs is actually the superman who
laughs or it's the wonder woman who
laughs or the specter who laughs or
something like that
and it's just a concept once this this
concept leaves this
you know ethereal plane and it goes to a
place like earth prime indies in the in
the dc comics uh then it turns into the
physical form of the spectre who laughs
or something like that right so it's
just
at the moment it's just thoughts that
can actually attack them uh but for the
most part the other thing that goes on
here is the actual confrontation between
the batman who laughs
and perpetua remember they're still
fighting over dominance of the universe
now perpetua
kind of plays this gambit where she's
like look you have to understand here
i'm the only thing that's holding back
those you know ethereal powers out there
from realizing what we've done right and
that's one of the things that scott
snyder kind of hit on here and this is
one of the things that also applies to
marvel comics right that
perpetua is in effect a kind of stand in
for like the one above all if not like a
step above that in marvel comics right
so in marvel you've got the one above
all
and then you have like whatever's above
it right if there even is anything
marvel's never said there is but if
there could possibly be a thing above it
then those seem to be the individuals
that
create a perpetua as well because what
vc's told us here
is that these individuals that created
perpetua and basically sent her on the
mission to create the multiverse they're
the ones who run the omniverse and the
omniverse is basically a collection of
multiverses and so
the omniverse in encases marvel comics
and in cases you know spawn comics and
different things like that and so
you know if we extrapolate this out and
we're really delving into the realm of
hearsay and just guesswork at this point
but if we if we extrapolate that out
then we can largely
make a reasonable assumption that these
omniversal entities that exist out there
that could
create a perpetua seemingly also created
the presence in dc comics they created
the one above all in marvel comics right
like they're the ones that are
responsible for seemingly
the existence of all things that are out
there now dc really seems to be playing
it pretty fast and loose with that and
basically kind of
and not even really fast or loose more
kind of hard line and saying they're
only responsible for the creation of dc
right so seemingly
these omniversal forces that are out
there basically represent like writers
the writers and artists that create dc
comics you know that really seems to be
the actual explanation dc is giving us
but if we move away from that actual
explanation and we kind of replaced it
with our own explanation
then they're basically the ones that
created everything in existence across
every form of media ever
right television movies comics actual
novels different things like that
the one thing we do know is that
perpetua was not supposed to do any of
this stuff you know she was basically
sent there for a task
she deviated from her task and now she's
basically gone awry and so her being
able to kind of block the actions of
what she's done
and the multiverse as it exists from the
eyes of these omniversal forces that
that live out there is really kind of
her saying
if you kill me they're gonna become
aware of what we've done and what i've
done and they're gonna wipe us all out
and they're gonna start all over again
right they're effectively going to
reboot as we call it and so the batman
who laughs is kind of like so who cares
and so going on the attack again against
perpetua ultimately he ends up basically
destroying her right he destroys
perpetua
and actually encases her back in the
source wall and then siphons off the
rest of her power right so he now has
100 of all this power across the
multiverse but the saving grace from all
this
really comes from wonder woman right
where the book that she has in her
possession is the one
that would allow her to basically kind
of tap into all this anti-crisis energy
and then use it for her own purposes
where her and lobo are basically
cornered then ultimately lobo kind of
sacrifices himself and says like i will
stay here with these copies of myself
and i will
basically fight off this this batman who
laughs as much as i can
get out of here right like i will be the
distraction get out of here as fast as
you can
and basically save the day the problem
with this is that she loses
the journal in the process one of the
batman who life forces basically gets a
hold of it and lobo essentially
sacrifices himself and so when she shows
up to the forge of worlds
then what this leads to is basically
this kind of formation of dark side who
says like
all is basically lost here there's
nothing you can do right in this moment
right now
what few hopes and fears exist out there
really what few hopes exist out there
come from your superhero
friends on earth but there's not really
anybody left right so there's no real
hopes here right so the possibility of
new alternate realities being created
based on the positive hopes of people
who exist out there
is basically null and void right it
doesn't really exist this forge is
dwindling out and when it totally burns
out it'll be because all your friends
died and then from there
no new life will be created it'll allow
the batman who laughs to wipe all this
away
and then basically re you know replace
it with the with his his depiction
of how life should be kind of like a
dark multiverse 2.0 basically
and so with that in mind wonder woman
kind of starts pondering all this right
and kind of starts thinking about all
this now the funny thing is once batman
who laughs overtakes perpetua he kind of
starts to reel back his forces
and and when they all basically stop
fighting that's when the superheroes
make the false assumption that they want
the super you know all the super
villains all these dark twisted versions
kind of stop and it's like okay we won
right we drove them back we demoralized
them right we basically saved the day
and that's when batman kind of hits on
the idea something's wrong here right
like
something's wrong like things are
changing right things are shifting and
that's when when even
jaro and almost anybody else who can
suddenly pick up on this starts to
realize
the earth is shifting right like the
earth is shifting it's adjusting it's
modifying
we didn't beat anybody we've lost right
the batman who laughed took over
perpetua she's gone now he has
absolute power across the multiverse he
is an effect god now there's nothing we
can really do to stop him but wonder
woman kind of starts to realize this
thing when she starts to realize as she
ponders this idea she starts to realize
what the what the journal had basically
told her that this machine quote unquote
kind of a loose term you know this
machine could be used to make everybody
remember
all of history right to unite everybody
in a single mindset
of we're all part of this massive
tapestry now the question is what does
this mean right what are the
consequences of wonder woman
taking this revelation that they're all
part of a massive tapestry and kind of
focusing it into the lasso and then
dipping it down into the world forge
what's the importance of that
okay so here's what this means right
here's why this is so significant so
let's wind the clock back to
to action comics number one with 1938.
that was the very first appearance of
superman in dc comics
because of the popularity of superman
you saw a whole bunch of other
superheroes being introduced but in dc
comics it wasn't until batman and
superman first crossed over that they
had a shared universe but in the
aftermath of that shared universe
suddenly it was all these superheroes
that exist out there all live on the
same earth and they all fight various
criminals and they can all team up at
any point in time
now in 1956 dc introduced barry allen
they basically got rid of wally west
they replaced him with barry but they
never offered an explanation as to what
happened to jay garrick and so dc fixed
this in 1961 i think with a flash of
two-world storyline and what this did
is it basically said any superheroes
that you saw out there in dc comics that
were fighting between like 1938 and 1955
or so
they were all basically from a place
called earth 2. all the superheroes that
you see now with like barry allen going
forward that's all
earth 1. they introduced the multiverse
for the very very first time now this
became very chaotic and it became very
hectic and so in 1985
86 87 dc basically rebooted with the
original crisis on definitive event now
in the aftermath of the crisis event you
got rid of the multiverse and you only
had
one universe right that was the end of
it it was just simply a place called new
earth and so in that universe a lot of
the heroes got new origin stories they
got new
new tales right new adventures different
things like that and that ran
all the way up until we got to the new
52 right the flashpoint event which
rebooted yet again
between those two stories we got events
like zero hour crisis in time where the
universe was kind of blinked out and
then blinked back into existence again
we got infinite crisis which brought
back the multiverse and then you got
final crisis which made the heroes aware
of the fact that the multiverse had
returned
but after each one of these crisis
events news stories were written
new origin stories were given and so
what's really kind of happening here
is is dc is basically telling us and
really scott snyder's telling us after
the events
of the crisis undefeated our story
nobody remembers anything
from before the events of christ's
uninfinite earth right nobody recalls
that
in the aftermath of infinite crisis
nobody really seems to remember the
events from before infinite crisis
in the aftermath of the events of
flashpoint nobody really seems to
remember anything from before the events
of flashpoint and then when it comes to
smaller stories like zero hour and
infinite crisis final crisis that the
heroes who were changed as a result of
those stories
don't really remember anything that came
before it right so it's kind of this
hodgepodge you know sort of organized
chaos among
all these different heroes in terms of
what parts of their history they
remember
what parts they don't right it's just
kind of a patchwork just gaps in their
brains
of things that just have or have not
happened what's going on here
is scott snyder's basically clean
slating everything and he's saying okay
so what if after the events of crisis on
invented earth heroes remembered life
before the events of the crisis right
they remembered like what life was like
before then they remember their origin
stories all that kind of stuff and then
they remember fighting
during the events of crisis on inventors
and they remember the singular universe
that came after
and what if you know in the aftermath of
the events of flashpoint
they remembered everything that came
before flashpoint they remember all
their history and all that kind of stuff
and so
instead of basically treating these
stories like reboots well the characters
were totally reworked they treat them
like events
right like it's no different than like
you know some some batman vs superman
story where like they fought for a
little while
and then they kind of go back to doing
what they were doing they recall doing
that they recall all that stuff so it's
basically dc saying
none of the reboots ever happened right
i mean i guess they did but like nobody
forgot anything
they remember everything right they
remember everything that ever happened
superman
remembers his life when his comics were
being published back in the 1950s right
superman remembers dying batman
remembers having his back broken by bane
and the original ban you know uh
was a nightfall storyline you know this
these are these are all now
incontinuity and so there is no such
thing in dc comics now of
that story is not in continuity the only
exception of that are the else world
stories
but like in terms of everything that's
ever been published in dc comics it all
happened now right it all actually took
place right there's no more
differentiating between the
the you know the the publishing of dc
before crisis and after crisis it
doesn't exist anymore
it's all in continuity stuff that's
basically what this means that's why
it's huge
it's a massive moment right it's it's
one of the biggest things and so
with all that being said wonder woman is
now completely powered by all this
anti-crisis energy and comes emerging
out with the intention
of facing off against the batman who
laughs more so than that
because of the fact that all the heroes
remember all their history now they're
unified in a way that they don't recall
because all the all the previous
adventures that they had together they
forgot about they now remember which
makes them even closer they're more
tight-knit than they were before because
they know the sacrifices the
the heroes that were lost that are still
gone like all that stuff
is is a huge great big thing now so this
is awesome it's colossal it's why i told
you guys
this is basically kind of like a reboot
not reboot right this is
dc's version of secret wars from 2015
with marvel comics is what it feels like
so with that being said guys we're gonna
bring this video to an
end probably the single biggest
development i'd say in dc comics in the
last 10 or 15 years if not ever but if
you guys are new here to comments
explain make sure you guys hit the sub
button to become part of the rob core if
you guys enjoyed this video make sure
you drop a like
and i will catch you all later peace
[Music]
you